there's a lot packed into chilling
adventures of sabrina's 36 episodes
alongside her friends family and coven
sabrina faces new and ancient threats
plus saves the world a few times here's
the entire timeline of chilling
adventures of sabrina explained from
pre-show history to the series finale
hundreds of years ago a group of
scottish witches fleeing persecution
were taken by boat to greendale
massachusetts by dorothea putnam but
these witches were no safer in greendale
and 13 of them were hunted and hanged by
ancestors of harvey kinkel sabrina's
first boyfriend the greendale 13 and
their coven were the earliest
incarnation of the church of night to
which sabrina's family the spelmans have
belonged for generations in the first
season of chilling adventures of sabrina
the 13 are summoned by the demon lilith
to attack the town this is the only time
greendale's original witches are
actually present on screen but their
story informs much of what happens in
the church of night and in greendale
especially as sabrina starts learning
more about how to use her magic
when sabrina spellman is born two things
happen her aunt zelda forges her
signature in the book of the beast
effectively taking away sabrina's choice
whether to sign when she comes of ages
of witch her aunt hilda also witnesses
sabrina's christian baptism which is
strictly forbidden by the church of
night this leads to hilda being
excommunicated from the church it also
causes friction between sabrina and
zelda and complicates sabrina's decision
to sign the book of the beast herself
sabrina's parents edward a warlock and
diana immortal are killed in a plane
crash when sabrina is very young
your father and mother were flying to
italy edward was giving a lecture at the
vatican when their plane went down
tragically
originally believed to be an accident
sabrina later learns their deaths were
calculated by father blackwood who saw
edward's progressive ideas as a threat
to the church of night
in the show's pilot sabrina's favorite
teacher mrs wardwell provides shelter to
a distressed young girl she finds on the
side of the road when she brings the
girl to her remote cottage mrs wardwell
is slain by the girl who then assumes
her appearance and identity it's
revealed that the shapeshifter girl is
lilith a demon from hell she's come to
greendale to manipulate sabrina into
signing the book of the beast lilith
believes this will give her what she
wants which is a shared reign over hell
with her beloved lucifer eventually
lilith reveals her true identity to
sabrina and the spelman family and
pretends to be a mentor to sabrina
sabrina turns 16 on halloween night her
boyfriend harvey really wants her to
celebrate with him and their friends roz
and theo but sabrina is expected to sign
the book of the beast and be fully
initiated in the church of night coven
she can't spend her birthday with her
friends and she'll be expected to leave
the mortal world behind her aunts allow
her to go to raz's halloween party but
she's expected in the woods before
midnight to sign her soul over to satan
while she's standing in front of the
book of the beast sabrina believes that
signing her name is a choice that will
allow her to embrace her power and
freely perform magic as a full witch
when she learns that she'll actually be
at the dark lord's beck and call she
panics and runs out of the woods the
coven follows but sabrina's cousin
ambrose prevents them from crossing the
spellman property line protecting
sabrina from harm
when lilith summons the 13 to greendale
it's part of a master plan to force
sabrina to sign the book of the beast
but by summoning the 13 lilith puts
greendale and the church of knight at
risk which means sabrina is the only one
who can defeat them and save everyone
sabrina can't do that without the full
use of her magic which he can only
acquire by agreeing to sell her soul to
satan in the season 1 finale sabrina
finally puts her name in the book and
becomes a full-blooded witch in season
two she starts using magic more
frequently and tells her friends she's a
witch this causes some problems
particularly in her relationship with
harvey sabrina starts attending the
academy of unseen arts more often than
she attends baxter high and she even
starts dating a warlock nick scratch
with help from lilith and nick lucifer
morningstar returns to his human form at
the end of season 2. he makes several
revelations which alter the course of
sabrina's life and the show perhaps the
most important one is that edward
spellman isn't actually sabrina's father
lucifer is sabrina is thus in line to
become queen of hell and lucifer needs
her to rule alongside him so they can
remake earth and hell's image he also
needs sabrina to blow the horn of
gabriel to open the gates of hell which
will allow the dark aristocracy to
attend her coronation on earth sabrina
refuses but lucifer isn't concerned
you will blow gabriel's horn at some
down in the clearing where you signed my
book
lilith meanwhile is furious about
lucifer's betrayal so she turns on him
and begins working with sabrina to stop
the dark lord's plan all lilith wants is
the throne and all sabrina wants is to
continue being a mostly regular teenager
with lilith's help sabrina attempts to
trap and imprison lucifer so he doesn't
destroy earth but they soon realize the
only way to trap lucifer is to put him
in a human body nyx sabrina's boyfriend
is the most powerful conjurer and binder
since edward spellman as an apology to
sabrina for initially befriending her on
the dark lord's behalf nick volunteers
to become the vessel and keep lucifer
contained this traps him in hell with
lucifer in his body and he suffers
intense trauma from the experience
sabrina then abdicates the throne and
makes lilith queen of hell which is all
lilith ever wanted in exchange lilith
restores sabrina's magic which she lost
for defying lucifer and resurrects the
actual mrs wardwell
while sabrina deals with lucifer in
season 2 prudence learns she's father
blackwood's biological daughter
blackwood's multiple attempts to return
the church of night to its old ways end
with him being scolded and punished by
lucifer so he takes his infant twins and
flees prudence and ambrose go on a
worldwide hunt to find her father when
they find him in scotland they discover
he's manipulated time to age both
himself and the twins up blackwood then
becomes a prisoner of the coven and
sabrina's aunt zelda becomes the new
high priestess the coven then turns to
hecate for power leaving lucifer behind
completely when sabrina frees lucifer
from nick's body she imprisons him in
blackwood's body though he doesn't stay
confined for long the hunt for blackwood
ultimately damages prudence relationship
with ambrose who asked her not to seek
vengeance on her father
when the aristocracy of hell decides
lilith isn't a legitimate queen sabrina
has to take her rightful place on the
throne all while balancing her life on
earth but the aristocracy also doesn't
recognize sabrina as a legitimate heir
to the throne they instead support
prince caliban a clay demon formed from
hell caliban and sabrina compete for the
throne in a series of challenges known
as the unholy regalia this requires them
to go back in time acquire certain holy
objects battle monsters and fight each
other caliban nearly wins by tricking
sabrina into giving him the final object
needed to claim the throne sabrina then
creates a time paradox when she realizes
her attention to the holy regalia has
doomed the world to end with the paradox
she's able to stop caliban and become
the queen of hell
shortly after nick becomes lucifer's
vessel and sabrina gives lilith the
throne of hell a group of pagans arrives
in greendale they are determined to
return the world to the old ones which
means sacrificing virgins to awaken the
green man and and the modern world the
pagans disguise themselves as carnival
performers and attempt to seduce
sabrina's friends into being sacrificed
in the end stages of the pagans plan
sabrina is too caught up in the holy
regalia to realize how desperately her
friends need her help before she figures
out how to go back in time sabrina gets
trapped in hell and the pagans kill her
friends luckily using a time egg
recovered from father blackwood in
scotland allows sabrina to stop the
pagans and save the world though she
creates a new set of problems in the
process
what am i
to prevent the pagans from winning and
stop caliban from becoming king of hell
sabrina is forced to manipulate time the
version of her that's trapped in clay
and hell is awoken by a different
version who has already fixed everything
this version of sabrina tells the
trapped version that she must close the
time loop by returning to hell and
trading places with her to stop the
massive ramifications in classic sabrina
spellman style she ignores this advice
and instead decides that life would be
easier if there were two of her so
sabrina spellman returns to earth while
sabrina morningstar remains in hell and
is crowned queen morningstar marries
caliban and contentedly rules over hell
with lucifer and lilith doing all of the
things spellman didn't want to do when
ambrose discovers what his cousin has
done he forbids her from ever being in
the same place as sabrina morningstar
again sabrina spellman abides until she
needs morningstar's help which you
guessed it causes major problems
after he leaves the church of night acts
as a vessel for lucifer and is then
given the mark of cain so he can't be
killed faustus blackwood decides to
unleash the eldritch terrors gods so
ancient they haven't been seen in
thousands of years of course they want
to end the world this power play is
spurred by blackwood's anger at the
spelmans particularly sabrina and he
seems to think he'll somehow be spared
when the eldritch terrors destroy
everything sabrina and her family are
able to beat back the eldritch terrors
at first even when blackwood uses the
perverse to become emperor of greendale
and rewrite reality however stopping the
most powerful terror the void requires a
powerful witch or warlock to sacrifice
themselves
the cosmic is the first eldritch horror
not to manifest in greendale itself
instead it begins to condense hell earth
and heaven until they bleed together
which ultimately leads to chaos an angel
metatron then arrives in greendale and
tells the coven that this chaos is the
result of there being two sabrinas their
continued existence has created a
parallel cosmos which is being pulled
toward earth to stop the inevitable
collision and the cosmic one of the
sabrinas must be sent to an alternate
earth sabrina's spellman and morningstar
both have lives on earth so they decide
that the fairest way to determine who
stays and who goes is to play rock paper
scissors morningstar loses so she's sent
away on the alternate earth she's an
actor playing herself in a tv sitcom of
her life surrounded by her family and
friends who are also playing versions of
themselves but the endless in the form
of an animatronic salem has turned this
realm into a never-ending sitcom for its
own amusement like the other eldritch
terrors the endless is working for the
void sabrina morningstar realizes the
problem and returns to the main earth to
warn sabrina spellman then dies from the
trip through realms
in a last-ditch effort to keep lucifer
from killing her lilith convinces
blackwood to sleep with her while he's
lucifer's vessel so she'll become
pregnant with lucifer's child lilith
intends to use her child as a means of
becoming queen of hell she schemes that
her child can kill lucifer to claim the
throne to make her queen mother when
lucifer tries to take the child from her
she kills the boy herself and makes a
meal of him lilith's final act in the
series finale is to stab lucifer drink
his celestial blood and then banish him
to wander the mortal world so she can
rule hell in peace
throughout chilling adventures of
sabrina season 4 the coven works with
hedge witches to try and stop the
eldritch terrors they quickly realize
they're out of their depth so sabrina
spellman tries to solve the problem by
trapping the void in pandora's box that
unfortunately requires her to sacrifice
herself her family isn't willing to let
her go so they summon her spirit back to
sabrina morningstar's body which creates
a war between hell and earth spellman
realizes she's taken part of the void
into herself when she starts
disappearing random objects caliban and
harvey's father she fears hurting her
loved ones so she flees to the mountains
of madness where faustus blackwood
claims he can train her to contain the
void black blackwood secretly plans to
rip the void from sabrina's body to
claim the power for himself sabrina's
friends attempt to save her but
returning the people sabrina
accidentally disappeared requires zelda
to cut sabrina open and drain the void
from her body this opens a gateway
allowing ambrose and harvey to put the
eldritch tears they've trapped inside
the void and retrieve the people once
everyone has been returned from the void
nick uses pandora's box to trap the void
forever sabrina doesn't survive and her
family mourns both her and sabrina
morningstar back in greendale chilling
adventures of sabrina ends with sabrina
and nick in the sweet hereafter which is
a much friendlier afterlife than any
others that have been shown in the
series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you